I can remember my earliest memories of
my parents taking me to the beaches in
New England where we lived and just
wondering about the mysteries that lie
beneath I think the ocean for me has
always represented this place of great
potential discovery and as I grew older
I just wanted to explore the undersea
world to get a great picture of a whale
or of multiple whales many things have
to line up
sperm whales are animals that spend most
of their life in the deep ocean and they
dive for foraging for squid in there
only at the surface for about 15 or 20
minutes at a time so for this story it's
ideal to get multiple whales doing
something interesting a mom and a calf
or babysitting behavior or socializing
behavior there's a euphoria I think an
exhilaration after having one of these
extraordinary moments with a whale you
can go weeks and weeks and months with
nothing great and then all of a sudden
something breaks
[Music]
the things I was seeing I was seeing
them opening their mouths and their
giant teeth and their playfully biting
each other and rolling around together
and doing all these things but on
another level
even beyond the image it's a personal
reward for the time and the patience and
you've got to experience something that
you only dreamed about before a lot of
the interesting science that's been
published about whales in recent years
is showing that these animals lead far
more complex lives than we ever thought
that for lack of a better word they have
humanity they're doing things much like
us they isolate themselves by language
by dialect they babysit they have their
own feeding strategies all of these
things are happening and I think to the
degree that you can do this with
photography and good storytelling we can
help people see the ocean in a new way
where all of a sudden you know this
light goes on and you realize that there
are these complex animals that have
personality and have identity and I
think if we can get people to to
understand that you begin to say wow you
know the ocean is not just this place
with cold blooded fish out there that
all animals have these interesting lives
I try to relate that humanity to these
animals and help people see a different
frame to see a different view of the
ocean in hopes of understanding that
everything is connected the ocean is
important to our lives every other
breath that a human being takes comes
from the ocean so there for no other
reason than our own self-interest we
should be interested in protecting the
ocean but hopefully it's more than that
hopefully we come to see ourselves as
part of this really complex equation
that the ocean plays a big part and it's
in our own joy and interest to celebrate
that
[Music]
[Music]